we got big war news uh shout out to
Raymond g Stanley Jr super chatting this
this is from defensenews.com house
drafts Bill to strike Iran proxies amid
Israel Hamas War ladies and gentlemen we
are on the precipice right now House
Republicans are runting a military
authorization that would allow President
Joe Biden to strike iran-backed proxy
forces throughout the Middle East if the
Israel Hamas War escalates into a
broader regional conflict Ford Affairs
chairman Mike McCall of Texas told
defense news on Tuesday he's drafting
the bill in case lebanon's iran-backed
militant group Hezbollah steps up its
attacks on Israel the prospect of
escalation comes as Israel continues its
weeklong aerial bombardment etc etc I
hope you guys are ready man because a
grain of sand the saying I often use how
many grains of sand make a heap where's
the off-ramp as to quote Phil lanti if
if if we're at the point where troops
are being ready for deployment 19,000
Personnel already there two two carriers
Biden is in route the peace talks the
humanitarian Aid Summit in Jordan is
cancelled you've got some kind of Riot
erupting in in in Jordan trying to storm
the Israeli Embassy and now the house is
saying we better draft a military
authorization to strike Iran yeah so ju
just kind of for background with me a
little bit I had worked on the hill on
the house Foreign Affairs committee and
so this this is an aumf right this is
authorization use of military force
these have generally been completely
open-ended we literally fought a global
war on terror for over two decades over
with the last aumf so where does this
end what's What's the de you know and I
don't see the uh the legislation in
front of me I don't know the language
says this is a slippery slope this can
be a very slippery slope we fought and
died and you know tried to eradicate
obviously terrorism all over the globe
and it was it was very open-ended uh
obviously we were attacked we had
um a very obviously emotional response
over that uh rightfully so uh but that
aumf continued on for a very long time
very long time and if I remember
correctly still on the books now I want
to give a a shout out to another Super
chatter cold leftovers who made a good
point
Joe Biden's heading to Israel right now
he's flying into into Israel Rockets are
currently flying through the
air the Super Chat
mentioned nothing bad needs to happen to
Joe Biden a rocket just targets or
explodes or in some way good point
causes some kind of interaction with Air
Force One that's it Air Force One Force
diversion after Hamas rocket nearly
strikes US president C it's almost like
they're provoking that just sending him
there right if if a rocket in any way
threatens the the presidential dispatch
or whatever that's that's that's that's
all they'll need to say look they they
tried to kill our president yeah that's
a big deal remember George Bush did that
he was like they tried to kill my dad
remember that that's right yeah well I
mean and but that wasn't a cass's belly
that was him winging that was winging
for sure but if we can winge like that
then what does this look like and kind
of the and we saw this even way back in
the day mujahadin uh in Afghan the the
asymmetric technology that exists for
terrorists which we provided obviously
to be able to defeat the Soviets in
Afghanistan stinger missile these are
heat seeking missiles which literally
rocket fired it's a man PAD as they call
it anybody really I mean it's got a
Seeker um it's pretty easy to use
they're all over the place the Russians
formerly Soviets also manufactured them
uh the sa versions they're all over the
place right now look obviously there's
countermeasures on air force one and all
these other things it does make me think
are they moving like these strike
carrier groups there also because he's
going there mhm interesting is that part
of the reason been planning to go there
you know cuz they moved these they moved
the uh aircraft carriers a like a good
few days ago at this point wasn't it
over the weekend Saturday yeah and they
do have a ballistic missile defense
system on these destroyers right so you
got the bmd uh ballistic missile defense
destroyers attached to uh strike carrier
groups which you're part of that uh
larger group of ships that go is that
you know I don't know it's just an open
question is that part of the reason
they're there so Joe Biden can go to
Israel yeah I don't know I don't know it
does make sense but it also also there
doesn't seem to be any reason like Tim
was saying there doesn't seem to be any
reason that he has to go to Israel you
know phone there's like just no reason
for that I mean how many times could you
schedule a meeting with someone to have
in person and then you just call them
via you know pick your video
conferencing or how about he meets with
all of these world leaders in Egypt in
Cairo right yeah somewhere more secure
or right there I mean the carrier group
the carrier group is right there next to
Israel Egypt Etc they could easily land
in Cairo and have the meeting there or
Bahrain literally oh yeah that's that's
where fifth Fleet is stationed is in
Bahrain I have been there they're there
centcom is in the region as well like
why not meet there
um just you know I mean but this guy you
know he's got this Napoleon complex as
it relates to his power and strength and
everything else that I think that's kind
of part of it and you know I think in
the back of his head Donald Trump's
always kind of eatting at him in a
little bit because Trump himself
projects strength he does Biden fallen
down set of stairs about every two
months certainly doesn't right and maybe
that's part of the thing I'm going to
roll two strike carrier groups here I'm
going to fly in here comes President
Biden you know but is he even making the
decisions I was say I don't know yeah
Riley's being very kind by has his own
thoughts going on you know but I was
also thinking today about when Trump
went and met with uh Kim Jong-un you
know that was like a great he walked
across the DMZ way different situation
there was I right was a war it it it is
a war but but but there's like periodic
Armistice or whatever you call it Donald
Trump meeting and walk
you know uh what did he walk like 100t
or something is an effort towards peace
at a time when bombs aren't being
dropped by multiple countries and you
know it was it was it's just not the
same kind of a smart move on his in this
it's Donald Trump was meeting
specifically with the Enemy leader to
negotiate peace this is Joe Biden
meeting with one faction's leader at a
time when Rockets are being fired back
and
forth right and there's tens of
thousands of them aimed at Israel to
their North with Hezbollah and you know
I mean for
me it's it's hard to believe just a few
years ago I mean Donald Trump was the
Peace president there was no Wars we're
not dealing with any of this stuff when
he was president and I mean that's for a
reason I mean people see us right now I
think around the world they see an
opportunity they see an opportunity to
do this stuff when he was speaking in
Iowa Trump was it yesterday he was
speaking in Iowa to yeah he said uh my
personality kept us out of War that's
right and he's definitely not wrong
about that sure yeah he's definitely I'm
I'm curious to see what would happen to
these Republicans who vote in favor of
another aumf I mean look they know they
can't beat Trump there's a reporting in
the Wall Street Journal today donations
to the GOP Rivals have stopped none of
these big donors want to give money to
losers anymore they're like these guys
can't win Trump's lead is growing he's
improving in the polls we're flushing
money down the toilet
yep people who are voting for Trump do
not want foreign intervention they do
not want more war they do not want World
War II I'm wondering what's going to
happen to the GOP uh members look
they're going to get a decent amount of
support I'm not saying everyone's
absolutely opposed to intervention but
30% I mean this this could this could
cause some of these guys to re-election
GP was a joke going to that debate I
mean no one had a presence at all the
only Trump's lack of presence was more
of a presence than anyone on that stage
and then when Nome showed up he was the
star Hannity practically made out with
him on stage I was like this is
ridiculous it crazy and then when I got
there people were telling me there
there's protesters on the street on the
way up to the Reagan Library I'm
thinking antifa like thugs it was Trump
supporters lining the streets of LA wow
because they're like we love Trump and
it was crazy you know the GOP is
completely weak yeah that is the the
weirdest move by Dan santis by the way
was you know to debate uh I mean it's
like he took the bait uh with um Gavin
Newsome over there and you know I I
think Gavin Newsome's arguably one of
the worst governor in the country he's
destroyed cforia he destroyed California
but the guy's pretty slick and I that's
not a good matchup for D santis no D
santis is horrible on stage he was a
great Governor terrible candidate yep it
makes you worri too because it's clear
that his campaign staff is not getting
the job done and you know those are the
same people that would end up in the
White House and you're kind of like if
if they can't run this campaign they
definitely can't run this country right
talk about Trump surrounding himself
with bad people first term these people
are terrible right and Trump had at
least discernment for sure this is crazy
what's going on man oh yeah well and
this and this is all premeditated on uh
desantis's part not saying Trump wasn't
thinking about who he's going to put in
the White House in 2016 but it was kind
of like is this going to happen I think
it is I'm praying it is and it happened
but then you got the entire
establishment basically sending letters
like we refuse to work in the Trump
Administration blah blah I mean so it
was was few and far in between right now
I'm I'm hoping people are looking back
at this and like wow what a peaceful and
prosperous time in this country it
really was despite all the nonsense that
was going on Russia hoax collusion blah
blah blah all this other
stuff I mean it really was a prosperous
and peaceful time for this country I I
often think over these last few years of
Trump's State of the Union that he gave
right before coid happened
and it was so happy and joyous you know
retired of winning type you know
language and as someone who taught
narrative studies fiction classes for 10
years I was like oh no we're too happy
right something bad something bad always
happens in the movie if they start out
happy or if it gets to a happy part if
it's not the end which I hope it's not
the end well going go bad and he dealt
with threats mhm in the way they should
be dealt with now remember Isis Obama
says Isis is going to be a generational
threat for the United States JV team JV
team you know they had restrained Rules
of Engagement Trump snuffed them out in
like less than a year right and then
what does he do he strikes solomani over
in uh Iran and is like don't mess with
us and he sent a message out there you
remember when he dropped a massive
ordinance penetrator on over there in
Afghanistan like yeah we're not playing
around anymore thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net